so our first speaker is semester dr. L
with my colleagues the mathematics
department he's up he's a good patient
professor and great kept around and you
know that's great math and he's also a
great colleague even willing to come
here and give a lecture so I hope you
enjoy it we'll have the usual I mean
your work and ask questions they'll have
the usual drawing for for some swag or
some book so stick around today thank
you so thanks for coming on a Sunday
morning I like to do math on Sunday
mornings but maybe that's not the usual
actually it's a real pleasure to give
this lecture at math mornings I came the
first semester I was here at Yale I came
to a math morning's event and I was
really blown away by the energy in the
room the type of excitement that was
here you can see it you know in the pre
activities it's actually for this talk
it's really fun to see people playing
with with building platonic solids or
trying to build platonic solids so it's
really fun I'm really glad to be giving
this talk ok so I want to talk to you
about symmetry and probably the first
highly symmetric geometrical object that
we encounter in our lives is is an
equilateral triangle so an equilateral
triangle it's a triangle where all the
side lengths are equal and that's
equivalent to the statement that the
interior angles are all 60 degrees now
you say it's highly sommore I say it's
highly symmetric but what does that mean
so you try to look for ways in which it
appears to be symmetric what does that
even mean
so for example one way is you could kind
of imagine drawing this line of symmetry
here so if you draw this line down the
middle of the triangle and you think of
folding the triangle across that line
you see that it meets up with itself
okay so not every shape has you know
lines of symmetry so for example if you
take a rectangle then this line which
seems a very natural line is not a line
of symmetry right if you somehow fold it
across that line you get something like
that
all right it doesn't quite fold up on
itself so that it that would not be a
line of symmetry but this one is and
there are a couple more if you notice
them
so emanating from each corner there's a
line of symmetry so there's three of
these kind of lines of symmetries okay
it's basically it you can try to find
any other ones but that's all you're
going to find so what about any other
types of symmetries you can also rotate
the triangle okay so you can rotate by
120 degrees to the right you'll bring
the triangle back to itself you could
rotate twice like that rotate by 240
degrees you also bring the triangle back
to itself or you could think about
roading rotating in the other direction
but somehow if you rotate once in the
left to the left
120 degrees it's the same as rotating to
the right by 240 degrees so in some
sense if we want to just think of if we
want to enumerate the symmetries of this
equilateral triangle we don't want to
consider that rotating to the left or
rotating twice to the right are
different things they're really the same
thing and so I ask you how many
cemeteries total now can you can you
find for the equilateral triangle what
do you say hmm three five nine six so
five is a very reasonable answer so
there are three there are three of these
lines of symmetry and then there are it
seems like two rotations right I can
rotate by 120 degrees and I can rotate
by 240 degrees now I could also rotate
by 360 degrees right I do three of them
but that's not really doing anything I'm
just rotating the triangle back exactly
to it in the same position but actually
it's a funny thing that mathematicians
we like to consider doing nothing as
actually doing something okay so that
that we want to actually consider that
as a distinct symmetry of any
geometrical object every geometrical
object even some crazy wacky one has at
least one symmetry which is just don't
do anything
just stay there that's a nice symmetry
so if you count you have three lines of
symmetry reflectional lines of symmetry
and then you have two distinct rotations
and then just doing nothing so I think
you have six six total symmetries let's
look at another very nice symmetrical
shape the square okay square is maybe
the first or maybe the second highly
symmetric geometrical object that we
encounter also and it's a it's a
quadrilateral with all four of its side
lengths the same or all interior angles
are 90 degrees and so if you start
trying to play the same game well what
would you do how many lines of symmetry
do you see in the square you have those
ones you have those ones you have also
which kind diagonal ones and then what
about are those it four lines of
symmetry what do you think thinks yeah
rotations we also have rotations so you
can rotate now and you can so if you
think about it you can rotate a square
rotate it again rotate it three times
you have really three different distinct
rotations of a square you can make that
would bring it back to itself
all right so how many total symmetries
are there including the do-nothing
symmetry
so you have one two three four different
reflectional symmetry x' so with lines
of symmetry four different reflections
and then the rotations you have three
different unique ones and then you have
just do nothing so I would say that
there are eight distinct symmetries of
the square so if you keep looking at
regular polygons okay regular n-gon
for n starting at three that's what a
regular triangle is okay so a regular
trying I mean a collateral triangle is a
regular three gun a square is a regular
four gone and then we'd like to look at
you know regular Pentagon's so regular
five gone six cones and so what we've if
we count just the number of symmetries
as of you know for the two shapes
already that we've we've seen what do
you think is there a pattern so far what
do you think 2n and it turns out that
indeed if you count up for a pentagon
you can look that through each vertex
going to its opposite face there is a
reflection on line of symmetry so that
gives you five exactly and then there
are four distinct ways of rotating it
around plus the do-nothing thing so
there are ten total for the Pentagon and
for the hexagon you see that through
each pair of opposite edges you can take
a reflectional line of symmetry through
the center of those opposite edges and
also through each pair of opposite
vertices you can also get a reflectional
symmetry so that actually gives you
again six reflectional symmetry x' and
then there are six rotations including
the rotation that does nothing so indeed
that number is really two times n so far
okay and now if you think of okay
regular three four five six gone we can
get
you know regular 29 guns we can talk
about regular 1,000 guns and somehow
when we go to the limit if you look at
regular n-gon 4n really really really
large it starts to look like a circle I
mean the side lengths are really really
small and as somehow n goes to infinity
the side lengths strength to zero and
you just get this nice circular shape
you can think of the regular end guns as
approximations for the circle so how
many symmetries do you think the circle
has yeah an infinite amount but
particularly if you go by the pattern
how many should it have to infant two
times infinite amount so you think what
why is that and if you think of the
circle
it's the similar type of situation for
the end guns so you have basically two
distinct types of symmetries you have
ones which are just so you look at the
center and you have you have
reflectional cemeteries but they can be
really at any angle really at any angle
emanating from the center you can have
reflectional reflectional symmetry so
these give you an infinite number of
reflectional symmetry z' of the circle
and then also if you draw the circle
then you have also the rotational
symmetries and you can rotate by any
angle theta and you will again get a
symmetry of the circle so they're
somehow a circles almost a circles worth
of symmetries of reflectional symmetry
and another circles worth of rotational
symmetries okay so in a very reasonable
and and
well defined manner there are actually
two times infinity they're kind of two
circles worth of symmetries of a circle
that you can see kind of from the limit
of the symmetries of the end gone all
right
so if you just look at arbitrary and
Gaughan's not necessarily the regular
ones they start to lose symmetry right
so if we look at triangles for example
if we look at an isosceles triangle so
on the Left isosceles means that just
two of the side lengths are equal and
the third one could be different so when
isosceles triangle I claim just has one
symmetry okay you can just reflect
around one axis and so you have one
reflectional symmetry and just do
nothing so really there are two there
are two symmetries for an isosceles
triangle and if you just look at and
what are they calls what does that call
when cycling or a scalene scaling oh my
goodness oh it's really coming taking me
back so a scalene triangle where none of
the side lengths are equal that is kind
of very very unsymmetric triangle
there's really no symmetry except do
nothing there's no reflectional symmetry
there's no rotational symmetry so you
can see that amongst the triangles the
equilateral want yeah
yes you're asking are they equal those
two triangles oh you're asking are that
is the top say the top the diagonal line
and the bottom line are they equal no
they're not supposed to be equal in this
picture
do they look equal yeah okay maybe there
should have made it more extremely not
equal looking no they're not supposed to
be looking people a very good point if
they were equal then you would get a
symmetry right very good
so amongst all the triangles the three
guns the regular three guns are really
you could say in a very precise way are
the most symmetric ones they have the
most number of symmetries they have six
whereas the other ones have only maybe
two or one similarly if you look at
quadrilaterals if you think about a
rectangle so then that has two
reflectional symmetry z' again these
diagonal ones disappear and then you
can't rotate by 90 degrees but you can
rotate by 180 degrees and so that gives
you so you have two reflectional
symmetry rotating by 180 degrees and
then doing nothing you get four
symmetries and if you take something
like this in the middle so what is this
call the trapezoid trapezoid then you
can really only just reflect around this
central line and so you get two
symmetries and otherwise that one really
looks not very symmetric at all and
there's really nothing you can do to it
okay to bring it back to itself so the
idea here is that somehow regular n-gons
are distinguished amongst all the end
guns by their number of symmetries if I
give you a regular n-gon and I tell you
it's number of Summit
you can tell me immediately what type it
is in this kind of classification and so
the principle the general principle
that's underlying this is that symmetry
determines geometry okay that some sense
if you have a geometrical shape or
geometrical object and you want it's a
good thing to look at its symmetries
that helps you actually understand the
underlying geometry and in fact it can
help you determine the underlying
geometry so this is a actually it's a
much larger program that was basically
enunciated in the inaugural lecture of
Felix Klein so he at the age of
twenty-three was made a full professor
at the university of Elan gun in Germany
in 1872 and kind of when he came in and
he became a professor he had to give an
inaugural lecture and so the inaugural
lecture that he gave was this one which
was very famous lecture and has been
called after that point has been called
the Erlangen program okay it's it was he
enunciated this idea at this lecture in
there long and felix klein he was a
nineteenth-century geometers and the
program was basically a formalization of
this type of notion this type of idea
that symmetry should determine geometry
and that we should understand
we should reformulate the axioms and the
principles and and the foundations of
geometry in such a way as to build in
the cemetery and and make the cemetery a
natural part of the development of the
subject and that actually the symmetry
of geometrical objects should be studied
right alongside with the geometry and
that the symmetry in fact determines
some of the geometry okay so this was
this is a reproduction of the front
cover of the finally the published
version of
of his lecture in Erlangen 1872 all
right so there are three-dimensional
versions of the regular polygons and
you've probably seen them they are very
famous they're called the Platonic
solids they're up here also if you
really work hard with these with these
sticks you can actually build them okay
but it's not necessarily it's not so
evident if you've tried out there to
actually build actually build them so
they have names this one is called the
tetrahedron you have the octahedron up
there you have the cube
you know the cube very well and then you
have the icosahedron this one up here
it's made of triangular faces and the
dodecahedron which is made of Pentagon
faces
so these were really important in the
history of mathematics there were
actually some Stone Age carvings rock
carvings of some of these I don't think
that the Stone Age people had quite
discovered the dodecahedron or the
icosahedron but they had certainly
discovered the top three basically they
made little carved dice out of them I
mean I don't know if they played dice
with them but they made little carved
sculptures out of them so they they
clearly understood the the beautiful
geometry that was inherent in these
objects and that some of them existed
and these just fascinated the ancient
world so in the ancient Greeks the
ancient Greek philosopher Timaeus he
decided that we should model the the
four natural elements of the of the
universe on these ellinon on the
platonic solids so for example fire air
earth water and somehow intimacies
classification the dodecahedron actually
was left out he just didn't really say
anything about the dodecahedron and then
finally later Plato and then later
Aristotle kind of thought well we should
add the dodecahedron into this game and
so they decided that wait they should
make the dodecahedron a kind of
universal organizing principle it's it's
like a new a new element which they
called the universe or which they called
the ether okay so there were many you
know ways of this was kind of part of
early early cosmology the 16th century
astronomer Kepler had a theory that the
six planets that were known at that
point so from Mars up to Saturn that
their orbital lengths and distributions
should be modelled on nested platonic
solids sitting inside of themselves so
the Sun
at the center I think he had the
octahedron sitting at Mars and then
there's an icosahedron surrounding the
octahedron which is supposed to
represent the V the orbit of Venus then
there's a dodecahedron surrounding the
icosahedron which is supposed to
represent the orbit of Earth and then a
tetrahedron surrounding that which is
supposed to represent the orbit of Mars
and then a cube surrounding all of that
which is supposed to represent the orbit
of Jupiter and then around all of that
it's kind of the shell of the outside of
the solar system you know you see that
in this globe model which is supposed to
be the orbit of Saturn and so if you
think that there are only six planets
and you think that the last orbit kind
of you know is the end of the solar
system then this makes some sense and I
mean so okay
Kepler finally after seeing a lot of
evidence to the contrary abandoned this
point of view but still these these
things really fascinated the ancient
world and and the modern world so this
this is a image it's taken this is a
reproduction of a plate from some some
drawings that were made after so after
the voyage of the HMS challenger which
was a British oceanic expedition that
was made in 1872 - 1876 and it was one
of the biggest oceanic expeditions at
the time they were trying to get close
to the poles they were trying to collect
lots of samples and one of the things
they discovered they they got some
samples of these with which they named
so-called radiolaria and these are tiny
little creatures they're about 1.1
millimeter in diameter and they can form
themselves into platonic solids so their
skeleton you can find icosahedrons
dodecahedron
in the upper right you see a you see an
octahedron so this was pretty amazing I
mean people thought wow these things
actually exist in the world they're not
just pure beautiful geometrical forms of
perfect shapes these are actually
building but some of the building blocks
of nature yeah these are real animals
they're tiny they're point they're 1/10
of a millimeter in diameter they are
real animals though if you look at them
under a microscope they look just like
that and they were discovered in 1872 oh
that's a cross-section so that's that's
they took one of these and they took the
cross-section those are some of the
cells that are inside the these these
are kind of protozoa they have very few
numbers of cells actually they compose
them all right so how first of all why
they're only five it seems kind of
random right if you think about what we
said in the beginning you look at
regular polygons in the plane well
they're infinitely many there's regular
three Gonz foregone five dong sik scon
up to every you know all the regular end
Don's for every end but somehow in
3-space there are only five so what is a
regular what what are these regular
polyhedra
okay these platonic solids so the idea
is that you want to construct them as
regular as possible you want shapes
three-dimensional shapes where all the
faces are regular n-gon z-- and then at
this at each vertex the same number of
n-gons meet up and these are these you
want to construct them in the most
symmetric way what is the most symmetric
way you can construct objects so if you
try first to build three-dimensional
shapes out of triangles right where all
the faces are equilateral triangles well
so what you can do first is with the
tetrahedron you can imagine that okay I
can take three triangles and have three
triangles meet at every vertex so do you
in the tetrahedron at every single
vertex there are three equilateral
triangles that meet at that vertex and
in fact it's true that at every single
vertex of the tetrahedron there are
exactly three triangles
equilateral triangles that mean so you
can do that in the octahedron at every
single vertex there are four equilateral
triangles meeting okay if you look at
that
spinning picture you see that you can
look at these models at every single
vertex there are four equilateral
triangles meeting and in the icosahedron
at every single vertex you see a five
sided shape there are eggs actually five
equilateral triangles meeting at every
single vertex and so you think oh great
so let's make it one where there's six
triangles meeting at every vertex so
what happens there there is such a shape
but if you put six triangles at a vertex
they form a flat the flat grid you can
actually tile the plane with vertices
with six triangles at every single
vertex you see right there you look at
those vertices there are six triangles
around each vertex but they don't kind
of fold up they just keep tiling the
plane so that's it you've run out of
space you can't put six triangles at
every vertex and actually have a shape
that folds up on itself so that's it
four triangles that's it four shapes
polyhedra regular three got the regular
3-dimensional polyhedra that are made
where each face is an equilateral
triangle and that at each point there's
the same number of triangles meeting up
so you start to see where the finiteness
comes in somehow in three dimensions you
just run out of room okay what about
trying to put squares so regular four
Gonz at the vertices well the cube is
nice it has three squares at each vertex
it's very nice
so you say okay great what about four
squares at each vertex is again you run
into the same problem if you try to put
four squares at a vertex
they don't fold up
actually tile the plane you can put them
perfectly into the plane so you can't
put four squares on a vertex and have
that shape fold up upon itself to make a
three-dimensional shape alright and for
the dodecahedron what you have is okay
so we're done with squares right there's
only one shape you can get by by putting
squares on the sides okay so what about
Pentagon's I want to put Pentagon's on
the side and you see that what is the
dodecahedron it's a shape where at each
vertex there are three Pentagon's okay
meeting every single one and then you
ask great
okay what about four Pentagon's meeting
well if you try you see that you can't
put four Pentagon's even and they won't
even tile the plane so if you put so if
you see in this picture what I've tried
to illustrate is what happens when you
take if you look at one of those one of
those vertices in the picture if you put
three Pentagon's meeting they make they
leave a tiny little wedge in space left
over and you can't stuff another
Pentagon in there okay that's what that
kind of flattened out picture is
supposed to show you so there's no way
to put four Pentagon's at every vertex
or even at any vertex in for in 3-space
there's just not enough room in 3-space
to actually accommodate that and then
for six cons you think okay fine so
we're done with regular five Gonz
okay what about a shape made out of six
cons six okay what could I do I can put
maybe three six cons at every vertex
already though I tile the plane with six
three guns at every vertex okay I get
the usual honeycomb tiling of the plane
and so that's it and seven guns and
eight guns you can't even put three of
them at any vertex right if you think
about the interior angles they just
won't they they're they're too much to
try to add up so you cannot put three
seven guns out of vertex you cannot put
three eight guns at a vertex and you
could just can't build any more of these
that's it you've just exhausted all of
space by trying to build
the Platonic solids so that's why there
are finitely many of them and that's why
I'm particularly there are five of them
so that that's that's basically the
proof and that proof is actually exactly
that proof is worked out in in plate in
Euclid's elements actually so it's one
of the big highlights of Euclid's
elements of geometry is that finally
that proof is contained in there all
right so if you add up if you look at
these if you look at these platonic
solids and you add up one of the numbers
of vertices edges faces you get these
numbers okay you just have to stare at
them and add them up so the tetrahedron
has four vertices six edges four faces
the octahedron has six vertices 12 edges
eight faces and the cube for example has
eight vertices 12 edges six faces now
there's something actually curious about
the octahedron and the cube and the
dodecahedron and the icosahedron do you
see something going on there yeah the
sum you mean it's very good yeah if you
add up if you add up the number of total
numbers here you get 50 to 60 to 62 and
what happens here if you add them up 26
okay so that's true that's true that but
in particular what's even more than just
adding them up and getting them the
numbers are the same they're just in
different orders right if you look at
the octahedron and the cube it's just
that number of edges is actually the
same but the numbers of vertices and
faces are just swapped and the
dodecahedron and the icosahedron the
number of edges is the same the number
of vertices and other faces is just
swapped there's something going on here
which is what we call duality so some of
these Platonic solids are so-called
duals of the other ones and here's the
idea is that inside of a cube you can
stick well this one's a little big but
inside of a cube you can stick an
octahedron where exactly at the center
of each face of the cube you can put a
vertex of the octahedron okay and that
shows you that the vertices and faces
kind of correspond by going from
flipping between cube and octahedron and
conversely given an octahedron that's
what that upper right picture is trying
to show give it an octahedron you can
stick actually a square inside and so
that at the center of every single face
there's a vertex of the cube the fact
that you can stick one in the other and
stick the one in the other this is what
we call dual these are dual objects and
in particular anything you do to one you
do to the other because they're both
kind of nested inside of each other so
for example the cemetery's of the
octahedron and the cemetery's of the
cube are actually they're the same
because every symmetry of the cube you
spin the cube around but inside there's
an octahedron and you'll spin that
around and inside that there's a cube
you spin that around okay and then for
these two dual shapes you see again the
same thing happens that inside of an
icosahedron you can stick a dodecahedron
so that exactly the each vertex of the
dodecahedron touches exactly at the
center of each face of the icosahedron
and conversely inside of a dodecahedron
you can stick an icosahedron and so that
each vertex hits exactly at the center
of the face of the dodecahedron so these
two are actually dual to each other
here's another kind of weird dual
relationship between various platonic
solids so the cube and the dodecahedron
are not dual to each other but magically
you can take a dodecahedron and then
fold it up to make a cube and conversely
you can take a cube and cut it up and
fold it to make a dodecahedron so there
are kind of these these platonic solids
all kind of have strange relationships
to each other and and really
investigating them and exploring them is
is really something quite fascinating
okay so what about their symmetries it's
a little so what did we do first with
the regular n-gons when we were trying
to enumerate the symmetries what was the
first type of symmetry that we just
jumped out at us right
they were the lines of reflection now
here I think what's a nice way to think
about the symmetries the first type of
symmetries are the lines of rotation
because you're in 3-space now you can
rotate through an axis okay so for
example take the tetrahedron there are
two different types of rotational
symmetries you can take a lot a clear
tetrahedron and you can take a pair of
opposite edges and take a line that runs
through the center of those opposite
edges okay that's what that picture on
the upper left is is depicting and then
you can rotate about that line 180
degrees if you rotate about that line
180 degrees you will exactly move the
tetrahedron back to itself so there are
you know however many faces there are
six and so there are three pairs of
opposite faces and so there are three of
these types of rotations for the
tetrahedron and then what about these
you can also through every vertex
there's an opposite face and you can
take a line that goes through the vertex
and then out through the center of the
opposite face and then there
what you're doing is you can rotate but
now you don't rotate 180 degrees you
rotate by 120 degrees you rotate you
know a third of the way around a
triangle I mean around a circle so you
rotate one third one third and so there
are basically two distinct rotations for
every pair of for every vertex and then
it's opposite edge so so there are four
vertices and each one gives you two
distinct rotations emanating from that
vertex so you have 8 total rotations of
this type okay so if you're counting so
far you have 3 rotations coming from the
from the pairs of opposite edges you
have 8 rotations coming from each vertex
through the opposite face and then you
have doing nothing so how many total
symmetries do we have 12 exactly so
indeed the tetrahedron has 12 rotational
symmetries and you can do the same kind
of analysis for cubes okay so for cubes
you have for example opposite faces now
you can rotate again by 180 degrees do
the opposite faces so you have to count
up the number of faces divided by 2 you
get the number of rotate of those types
of rotational symmetries through the
opposite vertices now you have actually
pairs of opposite vertices and here if
you look straight through I don't know
if you can see this you look straight
through the opposite vertices because
there are 3 squares that meet at that
vertex you can rotate 1/3 of the way
around the circle so for each pair of
opposite vertices you can rotate exactly
twice there are two distinct rotational
symmetries and so you count up the
number of vertices you divide by two and
then you multiply by two because you get
two distinct rotations for each one and
then there are other types there's one
other type which is you go through a
pairs of opposite faces if you draw a
long
through the center of opposite phases
you can rotate now four times right or
really three distinct times you can
rotate one quarter of the way around the
circle and you can get for each pair of
opposite phases which there are three on
a cube you can get three distinct
rotations that way so if you've been
counting up so far how many total and
then here's what's going on for the
dodecahedron okay you have a similar
story you have you have pairs of
opposite edges you can rotate 180
degrees you have the pictures start to
get a little more difficult so you have
pairs of opposite vertices you can
rotate 1/3 away around the circle
because you have three Pentagon's
feeding there and then you have pairs of
opposite faces which you can rotate
which because each face is a Pentagon
you have five things you can rotate 1/5
of the way around the circle and still
get a symmetry so again you have to
count up all those things and you get
these numbers so already we got 12 for
the tetrahedron okay we got hmm 120
exactly so if you actually keep track of
what's going on here with those three
different types pairs of opposite
vertices pairs of opposite edges pairs
of opposite faces since there are a lot
of vertices edges and faces you start
multiplying out the total number and you
get 120 and actually we didn't do the
analysis we only did the analysis for
the tetrahedron and the cube and the
dodecahedron and what about the other
three
or the other two sorry the octahedron
and the icosahedron why don't we need to
do the analysis for those somebody said
it because they're dual right they're
dual so the icosahedron is dual to the
dodecahedron and
any cemetry if you think of sticking the
icosahedron inside of the dodecahedron
right each time you do for example one
of these face to face fivefold
rotational symmetries you're doing
because there's at the center of each
face there's a vertex of the icosahedron
sitting at the center of each face we
are doing the face to face rotation on
this embedded icosahedron you're
actually doing a vertex to vertex
rotation okay and so you can do five of
those going around so that's is the
question
with the this one the dodecahedron yeah
yes dodecahedron yes yes yes ah so oh
you're saying if you tried to add
another another face in yes to both of
them simultaneously somehow yes well I
mean that goes back to yeah it's a good
it goes back to what we were saying
earlier which is this exactly this
analysis here right which is that as you
try to add exactly as you try to add one
face one extra face you know meeting at
every vertex to say the icosahedron at
the same time you would have to also add
another face meeting to the dodecahedron
and you just couldn't do it neither of
them can you do it so that's that's
really what yeah I mean both kind of
both shapes give you constriction and
let's see and the cube if you look at
the cube and the oh I didn't do the
analysis for the octahedron
do all the octahedrons there so for the
cube and the octahedron as your I guess
as you're adding one face yeah it's a
funny thing as you're adding one more
face to the cube you get this plane and
I guess know well okay the cube yes I
see what's what I guess what just
happening is that you you can add one
more face to the to the cube you'll get
this tiling and then the the I the
dodeca heat or the what am i trying to
say the that the the octahedron will
just sit you see how it has the
octahedron has a square in it right kind
of in sitting inside if you think of the
octahedron is like two pyramids there's
one pyramid on top and there's another
pyramid below and they meet exactly in a
square so I think that's gonna be that
square that you would get by by trying
to add one more one more square to the
cube while having the octahedron
embedded inside the cube that's it's a
good I never thought of it that way was
that your question
okay good
or was that an answer to your quiz okay
so let's see yeah okay so we get these
numbers and lying so I want to come back
a little bit to two climbs our login
program so underlying these numbers
there's not just the number of
symmetries okay so if we think of all of
the symmetries of each of these shapes
and even of the regular n-gons actually
you can do things to symmetry so you can
do a symmetry and then you can do
another symmetry and because each time
you do a symmetry you bring the shape
back to itself if you do two cemeteries
one after the other you will still bring
the shape back to itself so doing one
symmetry and then doing another symmetry
will give you yet a third symmetry but
if you know all the symmetries what
you're just getting is a kind of
multiplication law on symmetries so you
can take one symmetry to multiply it
quote-unquote multiply it by another one
that means you just do one after the
other and then you'll get yet a third
one it's just a symmetry again so these
have these these cemeteries have a kind
of algebra structure there's a kind of
algebra that you can attach to the set
of symmetries okay and so each so the
set
of cemeteries has a multiplication okay
by just taking one Cemetery doing
another symmetry and this structure that
that exists on the set of cemeteries is
what mathematicians call a group okay so
it turns out that the set of symmetries
of any object any any type of structure
forms what mathematicians call a group
it's basically just the most elemental
way you can think about formally just
what do you think about the rules of
multiplication and what can you do with
multiplication you can well you know you
can multiply you can if you have an
equation you can multiply both sides by
the equation if you have you know you
can maybe multiply by the inverse of
things on both sides of an equation
there's all those things you learn about
algebra algebra quote-unquote of numbers
you can do actually with symmetries you
can if you have an equation between two
symmetries you can multiply that
equation on both sides by another
symmetry and you'll still get an
equation between symmetries it's a very
nice and convenient way to think of the
cemetery's okay and now because all of
these platonic solids live in
three-dimensional space
what climbs they're long in program it
would tell you or is telling you or or
or kind of leads you to consider is the
fact that the symmetries
of platonic solids are somehow inside of
the cemeteries of all of three space
okay so if we just think of three space
you know where we live
as an actual geometrical object you can
move in this direction you can move in
that direction you can move backwards it
actually hasn't it I mean it is a
geometry and it has a symmetry group too
and what we're saying is that the
actually these all of these symmetries
of the various regular polygons a
regular polyhedra is if you think of the
origin of our three space as sitting in
the very center of these regular
polyhedra each of these is given by some
type of rotation actually that fixes the
origin all these fix the rotations of
all of these fix the origin and so in
fact the summit and the symmetries these
are these are particular versions of
symmetries that exist in three space
just like for the regular n-gons in two
space the symmetries of the regular
n-gons are particular cases of just
symmetries of all of to space and the
the the group of all symmetries of three
space is something which mathematicians
this is called so3 okay it has a
specific name it's called so3 and it's a
beautiful object and it coming along in
Cline's program understanding the
symmetries of three space helps you to
understand three space and one way to I
think very nicely think of the
classification of platonic solids is
well we what did we do before we did a
case-by-case analysis basically on
how many polygons can fit at a given
edge and we you know we ruled out we
ruled out various possibilities but
another very beautiful way of
understanding the fact that there are
only five of them is that if you look at
this group that's so three as a
mathematician and you realize Klein's
program the Erlangen program is kind of
telling you that you should think of the
symmetries of the Platonic solids as
sitting inside of the cemeteries of so3
and furthermore that all of these
symmetries there's just finitely many of
them for each given platonic solid it
only has finitely many symmetries so
then you just ask well what are all the
finite subgroups of the group so3 and it
turns out that they are exactly
classified by the the symmetry groups of
the platonic solids and also in so3 you
also in 3-space you also have two space
sitting inside three space so you also
have all the regular n-gon sitting in
two space and all of their symmetries
are also you can think of as cemeteries
inside of three space so you also have
all the symmetry groups of the regular
polygons and in fact you can prove as a
mathematician you can prove that those
exactly exhausts the finite sub groups
of so3 so if you look at all symmetries
of three space the finite subgroups of
that only correspond to the regular
polygons in two space and then the
platonic solids in three space and
somehow that's that's it there's no
other so again this is a reflection of
this of this Erlangen program that's
saying that somehow cemetry determines
geometry the fact that there are only
these finite subgroups inside the
symmetry group of all of three space
determines the fact that there are only
these finite number of platonic solids
and only those kinds of regular n-gons
into space so i think that it's and it's
a
I mean it's it's a it was a really
important philosophy clients philosophy
and it made a big impact on on
mathematics in the 19th and all through
the 20th century on mathematics and
physics and nowadays I mean it's not
it's completely unthinkable that we
would consider a geometrical object or a
physical system and not consider as an
integral part of the study of it its
cemeteries okay so I guess what I'm
trying to say here is that the the
symmetries of the platonic solids really
help you to understand them and I have
to say that I taught a class so last
year I taught a class here at Yale which
was called reflection groups so it's all
about and essentially the first three
weeks of the course four weeks of the
course is about the platonic solids and
their symmetry groups and doing these
calculations about the numbers of them
and what kind of structure the
symmetries have more fine-grained
analysis like we did today basically the
students told me after the first month
you know I pick I've been picking these
things up since I was a kid you know
there are toys that are made out of
icosahedra they're all kinds of but I
never really understood very much about
it until I was forced to do problems
that had to do with the symmetry and
it's true I mean for me to somehow even
becoming a you know a professor and
maybe in mathematics I mean until
learning and then teaching about the
material it I never really understood
how beautiful these shapes were until I
was forced to really be confronted with
their symmetries and the the the
structure that they have in the kind of
relationships that they have to each
other so I guess that's a that is a sign
that I should stop the talk thank you
ah that's I mean that's a good point so
why is the sphere not a platonic solid
alright well it's it's interesting I
mean in some sense you know we viewed
the circle as a limit of regular n-gons
right so we could use we could view the
symmetries of the circle as a limit of
the symmetries of the regular end cones
but you know there are only finitely
many platonic solids so there's no
infinite limit you can take of them to
get to the sphere okay
still that's not an answer to your
question I guess we don't even really
consider the circle to be a regular
n-gon it's it's kind of uh it's just a
limit of regular n-gons and i would say
that about the circle
it contains it's somehow useful it
contains all the platonic solids I mean
you can you know in clothes any platonic
solid in a circle but somehow it has so
many symmetries the circle the sphere
the two sphere itself that first of all
it's definitely infinite and it's a lot
more infinite and you can't really
understand it as a kind of limit of of
symmetries coming from platonic solids
it's it's just a much more complicated
object I think that would be the answer
I would give yeah
who invented geometry I would say that
geometry was already was probably first
seriously thought of when the advent of
Agriculture started because somehow once
you start planting things in a field you
need to start thinking about the
structures of your fields and how they
you know how your farm meets other farms
and I probably that was the first time
that people were really confronted with
the the need to consider geometry so I'm
not sure if there's any one person who I
would say invented geometry but it comes
I probably comes from agriculture so all
the ancient civilizations had some
understanding of geometry if you want to
build a house you need to understand
geometry if you want to make
measurements of the lengths of something
you need to understand geometry if you
want to build a pyramid you definitely
need to understand geometry so all these
ancient civilizations definitely had an
innate understanding of geometry as far
as you know our modern-day understanding
of geometry I mean certainly Euclid
Pythagoras I mean these ancient Greeks
there's also a lot of geometry
development in the ancient Chinese world
ancient Persian world it was all kind of
coming together at the same time
probably in the ancient world
yeah the animals yeah they are weird
right let's look at this again
yeah they live in the ocean they live
right here in our oceans so they live in
the Atlantic Ocean they are kind of just
drifting around but they do they do eat
you can see their mouth you see the
mouth it's right in the middle they do
eat stuff but they're tiny they're
really tiny it would be scary if they're
big but they're tiny tiny yeah yes
No
so that's a very nice question it is one
of these so called Archimedes solids so
let me see if I can come up so okay
sorry the question is okay so the
question is first was the observation
that I think we're back here the
observation that the so remember these
two came in a kind of dual pair the
octahedron and the cube and the
icosahedron and the dodecahedron they're
kind of dual to each other but it kind
of leaves out leaves out the tetrahedron
it's kind of by itself but you could
think of what thing can you stick inside
the tetrahedron you know if you try to
exchange the vertices and faces you just
still get the same number of vertices
and faces so really what's happening is
that if you put a dot and the middle of
every single face of a tetrahedron
you can put another tetrahedron inside
of it a smaller one and on and on so
somehow the dual of a tetrahedron is
just itself a tetrahedron so tetrahedra
are kind of self dual and you can ask
about the duality between any type of
polyhedron in 3-space so one very common
one is the soccer ball soccer ball is
made out of what is it a Pentagon with
five hexagons or is it a hexagon with
five Pentagon's
hex its Pentagon surrounded by hexagons
and then you so it's not a regular it's
not a it's not a platonic solid because
not every single face is the same type
of regular polygon but it's almost a
platonic solid quasi put they call it
quasi regular polyhedra maybe and it's
made out of two regular
polygons and it's these are also very
beautiful shapes and once you start to
ask well what are all the you know
regular type of polyhedra you can make
with two shapes or three shapes the zoo
of them starts to really explode and
there are many many different types so
if you look on the for example in the
Wikipedia page of Archimedes solids you
will find this nice list of them and one
of them is the soccer ball and so you
can describe the dual of the soccer ball
as one of these are community solids I
don't remember exactly what it is it's
it has triangular faces but I think yeah
it has well we could look it up after
the talk yeah absolutely that is a very
good question so just to simplify things
I was only considering the rotational
symmetries in 3-space when I was
describing these cemeteries but in fact
there are also reflectional symmetry so
you have to think of taking one of these
platonic solids and slicing it with a
plane and hope that it's a mirror image
on both sides of that plane so each time
you can find a plane that kind of slices
a platonic solid exactly in half that
will give you a type of reflective
symmetry and so the reflection
symmetries also you can classify so you
can slice for example a tetrahedron you
can slice through a vertex and through
an edge and that's basically it and on a
cube you can slice for example this way
or you can slice this way and that's
basically it and then on a icosahedron
there's a lot more different slices you
can make but it turns out every time you
do this it's
like you add a lot more things but what
happened with the regular n-gons right
if we just considered the rotations
there and of them including doing
nothing and then what happens if we
considered all rotation I mean all
symmetries including the reflections we
got to N and so actually the exact same
thing happens here is that if you look
at these numbers these are the numbers
of rotational symmetries and if we
wanted to know the number of all summer
trees including reflectional symmetry is
you just double each of these numbers it
turns out it's a very good question yes
well that's a very good question
yeah it's probably the expert on that
there are but they they can tend usually
to be infinite I mean you have these
triangles like ideal triangles and ideal
say n Gon's but then you also have these
kind of infinite versions and as far as
yeah and you in in hyperbolic 3-space
you definitely have versions of platonic
kind of solids in hyperbolic 3-space all
the finite subgroups of the it's the
same so3 yeah that's right you have a
lot more room you have a lot more room
because you measure things differently
there so you you can you have more angle
there's there's more room like triangles
for example are much different I mean
we're used to the fact that the interior
angles of a triangle have to sum up to
180 degrees and I think in a hyperbolic
plane it's not true right so you have
more room literally speaking you can the
measurement of area and distances is
different so you can get more of them
very good yes I think you have to talk
with Michael frame about that what there
are fractional dimensional geometrical
objects there usually look like fractals
and I imagine there is a theory of I
mean you can talk about the the symmetry
group of a fractional dimensional space
and you can ask for like in Cline's
program you can ask for the finite
subgroups of it and I don't know if
people have done that for particular
have to be parts of you have one that's
not embeddable yeah it it's a funny
quite sure what to say you know it's a
good question